three proven techniques for overcoming
procrastination to get the work done
yeah I mean obviously it's about
realizing that everyone starts out with
inherent strengths weaknesses and blind
spots and it's about turning blind spots
in and weaknesses and then relents
attacking weaknesses turn them into
strands to grow or Talent
but all the town in the role without
dedication probably won't be enough so
no matter how talented a writer is it's
so important that they consistently work
and they put the time and energy and a
lot of writers deal procrastination and
I I get writers sent to me who deal with
procrastination now you know if I was
working with the writer I would really
want to try to find out why they're
procrastinating what it is they're
avoiding what their fear what their
triggers are so it is a very
personalized conversation but I can
share three techniques that work for a
lot of people maybe and so hopefully
your viewers at least one of these
things might be helpful for them and I'd
suggest trying all three if none of them
work for you try to find some other
things but there's a good chance that
any at least one of the things might
help so here's the first thing that I'd
suggest trying out and I call it
breaking the glass and so there's a tale
of a know of a Zen master and he has his
disciples and he has the most beautiful
delicate wineglass ever I mean it makes
people cry it's so beautiful but like
any wind it would shatter and he's
passing it around so people to be in the
moment with this amazing glass and this
one disciple doesn't want to touch it
because he's so afraid right that he
would break it and any and the disciple
turns to the Zen master and he goes
aren't you afraid that you're gonna
accidentally break this thing of beauty
and the Zen master says in my mind it's
already broken and so how this applies
is so when a writer procrastinates
almost always they're trying to avoid
doing something because there's a fear
there's something they're afraid of
that's generally why we procrastinate
and so
what I will do with a writer is ask them
so let's say their per casting finishing
the script or starting the script or
ever what are you afraid of let's say
you finished the scrub and and you can
say rational fears and irrational fears
but what are you afraid of you know it's
different for different writers it might
be you know the really Scott deal and I
wrote metropolis that was my first ever
script and so if it went in and they
didn't think it was very good I probably
would never get another job offer
because anyone who's gonna hire me is
gonna call Ridley and say how was
metropolis and if they're like yeah
that's it so I had a real fear that this
script wasn't good enough I would never
get another job my agent would drop me I
was literally afraid that my golfin
would leave me and I would become
homeless and live on the streets eating
garbage had all these fears now some of
those are rational and some are
irrational my girlfriend loved me you
know she married me she was never gonna
leave me because I wrote a bad script
and I wasn't gonna all my friends
weren't gonna abandon me but there were
rational fears it could have ended my
career and my agent could have dropped
me those are absolutely rational fears
so first thing is like write down
everything you're afraid of and have fun
with the irrational fears because when
you write them all down the irrational
fear is usually lose their power and you
can say this isn't going to happen this
is just some crazy thing in my head this
isn't gonna happen this could happen
even if I thought it was unlikely my
agent would drop me it's still possible
so that is a what I would say a rational
fear so picked the worst rational fear
let's say for argument's sake the worst
rational fear is my agent we're drawing
so what we often do as humans is we want
to avoid pain we want to avoid our fear
and so we want to run away from it and
that is what often causes
procrastination so the breaking of the
glass is instead of being afraid that
you're gonna break the glass run to it
in your mind say the glass is already
broken so let's say the worst thing for
me is my agent is going to drop me so
what the exercise is I sit down and I I
really
by imagination to pretend that I have
written the script Ridley hates it in my
agent is dropping me I would literally
write out the phone conversation of what
I think she would say and what I would
say try to be very realistic how I think
this would happen and what I'm looking
to do is to fully experience it
happening I mean you should feel
terrible you should feel like you should
really believe your agent has just
dropped you or whatever it is that your
worst fear is you should experience it
and then you feel terrible take a couple
deep breaths and then write what would I
do in that situation what would really
happen and I realized in that situation
I would learn from my mistakes I would
write another script I would try to get
better I would try to get another agent
there's no guarantees that I would but I
wouldn't
when wouldn't be the end of me and I
still would be in this wonderful
relationship to have all my friends if I
had to there's other things I could do
to make a living and I realized like
it's not as bad as I was imagining and
it takes the power away from that fear
and also what I see a lot in writers is
when they do that they're like you know
what if I do write this script and it
ultimately fails I want to go down
swinging I want to write the script that
I would write I want to follow mine
things I remember an agent told me that
once which is the worst feeling is when
you don't listen to your instincts and
you fail if you listen to your instincts
and it ends up failing you can sleep at
night and you can learn from that so the
breaking of the glass is imagine your
career is over or somebody's like the
greatest thing is I'd write the script
and it wouldn't succeed and I would I
would quit writing okay so imagine that
imagine you wrote the script and it
failed would you really quit right and
if you did what would happen and or
would you not quit would you right now
and experience the worst thing come
through the other end and realize it's
not as bad as I thought and I'm gonna be
okay and then you're not as afraid of
that anymore
and it diminishes the fear even a little
bit and if you could diminish the fear a
little bit that might be all you need to
get back on track and right now I've
worked with writers with with chronic
procrastination issues and they
literally every day as part of their
practice they'll do this exercise for 20
minutes every day before they start
writing that's pretty hardcore most the
people they'll do it two or three days
and then they get going on the script
and then they'll just use this exercise
when they need to when they're really
stuck and fearful they'll use this
exercise so that's one thing that
writers can try and it doesn't work for
everybody but it it has worked for far
more writers than it hasn't and
sometimes it just helps a little bit and
that's all you need but sometimes it
helps it profoundly helps the writer so
takes 20 minutes to try it see what
happens so that's one one thing that
someone can do here's a second thing
that someone can do who suffers a lot
with procrastination and this one has
worked for almost everybody this has a
very high batting average so one of the
things in addition to why are you
procrastinating I'm always interested
when I talk to a writer what do you do
when you are procrastinating what do you
do besides writing and you get and very
interesting bizarre range of answers you
know from watching TV to playing video
games to things I don't want to talk
about in this interview and you know
lots of different cleaning obsessively
cleaning the house and whatever okay so
what I the exercise how I'll train this
writer is okay so I want you to like
list out different things that you could
be writing not scripts nothing with
stakes that would be really really fun
really engaging you know some people
they like write really angry letters to
people in their lives if they're not
going to send or I had someone who's
like I've always wanted to be a stand-up
I don't think I'm funny but I would love
to write
I had someone she was in France and she
was I've always wanted to write an opera
just for like the hell of it I've had it
I had someone say I've always wanted to
write a porno film I just think that
would be so much fun why not
right so you make a list of things that
and and these are obviously going to be
things probably that you would never
think you're gonna make a living doing
well you know writing angry letters to
your parents or people that wronged you
you're probably not gonna make a living
doing that so then what happens is okay
you have your script and you're supposed
to be writing your script you have time
set aside this two-hour block to writing
my script and you're not writing then
what you're gonna do when you
procrastinate is one of these things so
you're gonna be writing your opera
you're gonna be writing your porno film
you're right angry letters or forgiving
letters or whatever it is because here's
the thing when someone's at the keyboard
writing it's so much easier to slip back
into the script so what I'm training
people to do is use writing as their per
cap as their procrastination tool from
writing so instead of writing so you're
not writing so instead of watching video
games or cleaning or whatever it is
you're doing you're not writing so
instead you're writing and what happens
is it's so much easier for them to just
slip back into writing so that can be a
really effective tool and I found that
that works for a large number of people
so take that out for a spin and see what
happens maybe that can be helpful so a
third and final tool and I'd say this is
one I really need to get to this is a
little bit of breaking the glass in case
of an emergency so it was a really
really hard hard case to solve that the
breaking the glass of running at what
you're afraid of as opposed to running
away and experiencing it coming out the
other end
and or using writing as a
procrastination tool they're not working
so this is like okay we gotta do
something hardcore for you then I use
the exercise of breaking the routine and
so what I do is I say I want you to set
up a space
where you right you maybe already have
one ideally a separate room not everyone
can do that but if you have a room where
you work and you can literally have a
room with the door like an office or a
spare bedroom or some part of the house
it could even be a closet I've had
people like clean out a closet and use a
closet because they're in an apartment
but you you don't have to have the door
but it's great if you have a door and
when you go in this physical space and
shut the door
that's your writing space and the rule
is that when you're in your writing
space you have to be writing you you
finger is happy moving across the
keyboard and at the moment that stops
happening you must get up and leave that
room because that is a writing room it
is not an on writing room it is not a
procrastination room now when you leave
the room you are going to leave for five
minutes and only five minutes and I'll
say why in a moment and I want you to do
something in those five minutes that can
help try to get you back into a writing
space so maybe it is maybe you do go
write something but not in that room
somewhere else or some people play the
guitar
some people journal some people just do
a fast walk around the place
some people might meditate Yoga
experiment with things that help get you
out of your fear to help Center you back
into a calm centered space five minutes
on a timer you can't take more than five
minutes because the part of you that is
trying to there's a part of you that
doesn't want you to write you have to
understand that there's a you know we
have this like lizard brain structure
and we have a part of us that tries to
prevent us from suffering like if you
put your hand on a hot stove you'll pull
it away and that part of us doesn't
distinguish between physical pain and
emotional pain so I remember when I was
in high school
hair fiber girls and I remember being at
the dance and I'm like I'm gonna ask
that girl to dance with me and I'm
walking over there and my lizard brain
is like don't do it don't do it don't do
it everyone's watching you not true and
she's going to say no maybe and it's
gonna everyone's gonna ridicule you and
your whole life you're gonna be known as
the
they got turned down by Jenny don't ask
her and it was all that like my
heartbeat the adrenaline the
fight-or-flight mechanism was going off
and it was terrifying that's why there's
so much alcohol with the mating ritual
because the alcohol can calm that down
so there's a part of us that doesn't
want us to write because if we write we
can fail and we can be rejected and that
really hurts and that can feel really
bad and our survival mechanism might
want to stop us from that so the reason
we only go do something for five minutes
is if it's longer than the part of us
that doesn't want us the right goes oh I
procrastinate you leave the writing room
for a long period of time I have power
over you know five minutes and then you
go back and you're right now let's say
you go back and you you get up you leave
that room and you something for five
minutes could be the same thing and you
go back in the rule is you're never not
writing in that space that's the writing
space you're just like I say insomniac
so if you're having trouble sleeping you
should get out of bed and you shouldn't
stay in bed you don't want a muscle
memory train yourself that you can stay
in bed and not sleep you're not going to
you you only write in that room and when
you go in that room I mean literally if
you have to just force your fingers to
go across the keyboard and do nonsense
because at least that is the motion of
writing and then just try to write and
if you only write for like 20 seconds
and then you like freeze up and you
procrastinate you get up for five
minutes and I have this is really
hardcore cases but I'll have people that
for weeks on end they're in that room
for 20 seconds a minute two minutes and
then they keep doing the five minutes
and if you were to watch them they're
constantly leaving the room for five
minutes playing their guitar or
meditating going back in that room at
some point they get so fed up with
leaving that room and the here's the
other thing in real life if you have
someone who keeps coming into your
workplace when you're writing and saying
you shouldn't be writing this isn't any
good you're no good yeah this could fail
this isn't safe and they have power over
you if every time they show up you leave
and you don't listen to them you just
walk out over time they're gonna stop
showing up so that's breaking the
routine
you just always leave that room and do
something for five minutes that can help
calm you and center you then you go back
in that room and some people don't do
that for a week and then they're able to
write for five or 10 minutes and then
they start to procrastinate and then
they it becomes a muscle and then at
some point they can't remember that it
was ever perc a station was ever a
problem for them i was i really suggest
doing the break the glass exercise and
the making writing your procrastination
tool before you do this because those
are quicker in in the majority of cases
they will do the trick
but if they don't this is a more
hardcore tool that you can try and so
far i've never worked with anyone that
some combination of this didn't didn't
work it's not to say that someone
listening to this will try all three and
it won't work but i think most people
who are listening to this if they
struggle with procrastination yes i hope
i hope that at least one abuse or some
combination will do the trick because i
used to procrastinate and i hate it it's
like it in the day i feel so exhausted
from not like the energy of not working
and and resisting something eyes just
it's so life draining it's terrible and
I know people that get into the habit of
that and that's just it becomes habitual
exercise for them so these are ways that
you can get out of that habit so
hopefully anyone is suffering that way
one of these will help
you